right good evening everybody
foreign
welcome to the September cabinet meeting
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the officers by the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber please switch off or turn to
silent your mobile phones and do not
make or receive calls while this meeting
is in progress please note this meeting
is being live streamed for members of
the public the meeting will also be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the internet does anyone intend to film
the meeting
nope
the follow members have asked to speak
under Council procedure rule 20.1
item five uh councilor Christian bright
Council of fellows and councilor Davis
items seven councilor Rogers item eight
councilor Rogers item nine Council of
bayford
item 12 counselor Davis item 14
councilor Rogers and item 15 councilor
Christian Bryant are there any other
members wishing to speak under 20.1
yes please leader I'd like to speak
under item five thank you
thank you Council of Ghana
is that it thank you
Kevin is all here so there are no
apologies does anyone have an interest
to turn the items of business on the
agenda this evening
not seeing any thank you minutes of the
previous meeting uh to approve the
summary of recommendation decisions of
the cabinet meeting on the 27th of July
cop is attached to the agenda pack I
propose to take the minutes as red do I
have a secondary seconded by councilor
Yates do members of Gray
thank you
minutes of the extraordinary meeting for
the summary of recommendations and
decisions of the extraordinary meeting
held on the 10th of August copy is
attached to the supplementary agenda
pack proposed to take the ministers red
do I have a second up counselor album
thank you the members agree
thank you
we move on to item five which is the TDC
and Parish and town council's
collaboration report
following the scrutiny panel review
which is me
in July of 2022 the overview and
scrutiny panel commissioned the
collaborations working party to review
how the council could improve working
relationships with parish and town
councils for better service delivery for
thanet residents the review reported its
findings back to the ons panel who in
turn recommended them to Cabinet these
findings in the form of the working
party's final report are attached to
Annex ones the report
subsequently the council's corporate
management team have looked at the
recommendations from the working party
and have raised no issues with any of
the recommendations and they've already
nominated the head of neighborhoods as
the dedicated officer point for parishes
contact in the council
from my perspective as leader I welcome
the ideas put forward and I thank the
working party and the scrutiny panel for
their time and efforts we do have a
variety of Parish and town councils and
I can only see that working more closely
with them can be beneficial both for
counselors and residents
so I have five people to speak
are going to propose
sorry so I am going to uh propose the
recommendations in the report
highlighted in section three
and covered in more detail in the review
report attaches nx1 the members agree
it's only the second or first seconded
by Council the eights members could
agree thank you okay get ahead of
ourselves this evening Castle bright
thank you leader good evening everyone
so for those who don't know me um as
well as being the TDC Ward councilor for
Viking I'm also the a member and a
current in the current chair of
broadstairs and St Peter's Town Council
over the summer there are a lot of
complaints about the conditions of the
various guns on the seafront and
councilor Alvin was kind enough to come
and join me to inspect them now as the
conversation went on
um he suddenly switched hats from uh the
cabinet portfolio holder to to the chair
of Ramsgate Council and gave me some
advice on what we might do to expedite
some some work
um fast forward to this Tuesday and I
was joined by several other members
several other double Hatters on TDC and
broadstairs in Saint Peterstown Council
where we met we're TDC officers and came
to an agreement on how we can work
together to improve the gardens in in
broadstairs
and that for me in a nutshell is what
this this is all about it's about town
Parish councils faced with challenges
and sharing best practice to identify
Solutions and cooperating with the
district council to bring those
solutions to life
um everyone in this chamber is aware of
the challenges faced by local
authorities as a star of the budget by
national government and until we get
over government with vision to invest in
public services it's up to us to take a
more creative approach to problem
solving as the level of government
closest to communities our town and
Parish councils work closest with
Community groups experts and volunteers
who go above and beyond in their local
communities every single day and our
willingness to collaborate with town and
parish councils is going to be key to
unlocking the talent and enthusiasm and
Goodwill of all those across thanet and
provide a springboard for creative
thinking and getting things done I'm
therefore really supportive and really
grateful to the um to the I've I've been
scrutiny panel from last the last
Administration
and to the officers for for this great
report thank you very much
thank you councilor blyatt don't think I
need to uh comment on that I'm sure I
agree with you councilor fellows
uh thank you later I'm speaking this
evening not just as the chair of
scrutiny but also as a parish counselor
a role I must add that I take equally as
seriously as my TDC roles this excellent
review was led by your very own
councilor Curry and as the ability to
become the blueprint for working
Partnerships never seen here in thanet
between councils of all levels I think
the spirit and direction of the review
is first class we give thanks to our
town and Parish clerks and or chairs who
gave up their time and thoughts when
putting this review together and we're
encouraged that all town and Parish
councils are willing to get stuck in and
take on more tasks in their areas but
this does have to come with some support
be it Financial or administrative I
think now is the time to give town and
Parish councils more autonomy they so
long for to enable them to become even
bigger powerhouses of local local
representation than they already are
this review will also lead to give
Clarity to Residents who is responsible
for who and what in their areas
also the recommendations in this review
have been agreed by all senior officers
and I hope the cabinet will agree to
them too
this will inevitably lead to further
recommendations coming forward in the
future which can only make our areas
better for our residents we hope that
Margate Town gets its own Town Council
soon and lastly I'd like to add thanks
to the officers from democratic services
for putting their help in when putting
this excellent review together thank you
um thank you Council of fellows
um again I don't think there's too much
I need to add to that except to say
perhaps that this Administration is
um fully supportive of Margate having
its own Town Council and I think in
terms of what we're proposing here it
clearly makes a lot of sense because
having one area which isn't parished
um clearly isn't ideal if we're going to
work more closely with our town of
Parish councils which is certainly
something that I'm keen on
uh
uh thanks for that councilor Davis
thank you leader good evening everybody
um I'd like to just support what my
colleagues have said about this a superb
report and a very very good intent you
know desired outcome
um
I'd like to highlight the fact that with
certain departments we need to address
it and that isn't there at the moment
because we have had my colleague
councilor Rogers and I and Cliff said
have had numerous uh issues recently
particularly with one department and we
are we are fairly clogged with people
requesting assistance from the parish
council because they're being ignored
and it's past the deadlines on some
issues I understand this is being
reviewed but I think it's really
important because they are very very
keen to collaborate with us but if
they're being ignored by officers and
told we don't answer you that's
obviously not acceptable with regard to
any financial implications we had
excellent training earlier this year
when we were all elected and I'd like to
propose that that training is extended
at the same time as it's done here to
members of the parish councils and town
councils because that would have minimal
Financial implication but would mean
that there was joined up thinking and a
standard if you like of training across
the different councils because there is
a there is variation there but again I
welcome this report and thank you all
for excellent work
yeah thank you councilor Davis um I
think there are opportunities for shared
training sessions we've talked about
that in the past in respect of planning
in particular because uh obviously the
the parishes and towns are
consultees on the planning process and
it would make sense that they have the
same level of knowledge as far as we can
achieve that through the transitional
for their other opportunities is there
any particular issues um at the cliff
saying Parish Council wants to bring to
my attention I'll be happy to look at
them not that I have a particular
interest in Cliff said but obviously
that you know but that but that's that's
true generally you know if people do
find that the system doesn't work then
then come and talk to cabinet and we'll
do our best to assist
thank you yeah we we also work on this
report and the recommendations contained
within it which are both sensible and
practical
we think it's important in the current
difficult times to look at how the
different tiers of Local Government Can
best work together while being mindful
with our district councilor hats on that
we don't see Parish Council and town
councils as cash cows because of their
flexibility with the precept
one particular good example of how
collaborative working between the
councils can improve things for
residents is the local litter forums
currently being expanded across the
district using the model set up in
Ramsgate by among others my colleague
councilor Austin and Neil Jones from TDC
in 2018
I do have a couple of questions
firstly related to litter forms can we
make sure that local councilors
are informed about changes happening in
their Wards before they happen so that
they can help with communication to
residents
an example from last week the dog poop
bins were removed from a park in my
world last week causing an amount of
upset among some residents if we'd have
been told about this beforehand I could
have explained the reasoning behind it
to Residents and that would have
lessened some of the Fallout
secondly
can you let us know when the other
overview in scrutiny report from the
coastal waste working group will be
published thank you
um I think that we have to be a little
bit careful in terms of requiring every
operational decision to be notified to
more counselors I don't know Mr Humber
do you want to comment on the particular
issue of bins being removed and whether
that's feasible
uh yes thank you leader um so we are at
the moment looking at the number of bins
um district-wide some of the uh dog poo
bins have been removed and where that's
the case
um an assessment is made of whether
there's a bin nearby whether the bin is
being used we've got data on that now on
how much bins are being used and an
assessment of how you know of that need
where there is a need and there isn't a
street bin nearby then a bin will be put
back in its place as for
um alerting certainly if it's
sort of possible operationally you know
if it's a planned removal of a bin then
uh yes we'll certainly do our best to
tell
um Ward members about that
um sometimes
just operational need if something's
damaged or broken or needs removing
quickly that may not be possible but but
yeah I see it's a good idea to you know
to to consult on that and let people
know what's happening I agree
I don't have an answers for the second
what's your second question unless Mr
Hughes is going to volunteer one
um I think it's something we'll have to
get back to you about but obviously
we'll be coming to cabinet in the usual
way
was accomplishment has been updated
okay well I think we'll look into it for
you
thanks
uh members I'm getting ahead of myself
this evening because I've already asked
you to agree twice but I don't think
there was ever any doubt we're going to
agree the recommendations
counselor Alvin yeah thank you later
um if I can just make a point here that
um
the collaboration between
TDC and Parish councils and town
councils has already been undertaken uh
by the the waste waste recycling Etc uh
even this lunch time I had a meeting but
it should have been all the town
councils but only broadstairs turned up
um which we resolved several issues
there and I made it clear to them and I
made it clear to all if the parish or
Town Council was
uh want to speak want to talk to me
about anything in relation to waste
recycling or whatever else I'm doing in
coastal whatever I'm always happy to
come to a Town Council or Parish meeting
if I can so I think from my point of
view and as I said this afternoon it is
very very important being a being a
chair of Ramsgate Tech Town Council to
ensure that the collaboration and the
communication between the parish town
and sanit District Council operates
openly and clearly and then we can work
together at the end of the day we all
want the same thing whether it's a Town
Council Parish Council or authentic
District Council so if we can work
together then then that is then that's
the way forward thank you
thank you councilor Alvin sober one
final time um you know what the
recommendations are we agreed thank you
try and do it in order for the future
items
item six is the adoption of the Westgate
on sea neighborhood plan
which is also me
under the localism ACT 2011 neighborhood
plans can be prepared by local
communities in the led by Channel Parish
councils or a neighborhood Forum in
areas which do not have a town or Parish
Council if that District Council adopts
a neighborhood plan has the same
significance as other development plan
documents such as the local plan let's
go on Sea Town Council has prepared a
neighborhood plan which has been
examined by an independent examiner and
the decision statement was issued by the
council that the plan should progress to
referendum as agreed by cabinet on the
15th of June the referendum took place
on the 31st of August the result was
that 553 people voted for the
neighborhood plan and 135 voted against
as more than half of those who voted
voted in favor of the neighborhood plan
the plan now comes into Force as part of
the development plan and the council
must formally make which means adopt the
plan within eight weeks of the day of
the referendum I therefore proposal
recommendations as set in there in the
report that is the Westgate on sea
neighborhood plan is recommended to a
meeting of full Council
to make that doesn't quite make sense
social starter again the west gate or
the we recommend to a meeting of full
Council that the westgate-on-sea
neighborhood plan is made
to have a second
Ed by accounts for the Yates any
discussion
members of Gray
thank you
Isom 7 is the broadstairs flood and
protection scheme which I believe is
counselor album
somewhere
the broadstairs flood and Coast
protection scheme is funded via the
environment agency and local Levy grab
funding the scheme is 100 grout funded
and the grunt allocate at the grunt or
even the grant allocation is 880 000
pounds the scheme is included in the
2324 Capital program
the pier or Jetty at broadstairs was
first constructed 250 years ago and
plays a vital role in retaining and
stabilizing the beach
it is the beach in combination with the
more recent concrete sea defenses that
protect the low-lying Residential
Properties situated directly behind the
beach
the scheme will reduce flood risk
or flooding by the sea to properties on
Harbor Street in broadstairs and also to
the rear of Viking Bay
with the effects of climate change
causing sea level rise and increased
intensity and regularity of storm events
the risk of doing nothing is that these
low-lying properties will experience
flooding more regularly
The Jetty is an important Beach control
structure and if damaged or lost it
would have the effects of narrowing the
beach profile at Viking Bay leading to
the frequent flooding and damage to
property and would also allow Cliff
erosion to restart threatening the
Promenade and assets behind
the scheme includes Works to the facing
blocks of the pier repairs to the
fisherman's slipway
repairs and improvements to the Sea
walls repairs to the steps to the
foreshore resurfacing of the harbor car
park and the installation of floodgates
for the use during predicted storm
events
the scheme will improve the standard of
flood defense from the current one in
ten year standard to one in 200 year
standard planning permission for the
scheme was granted in June this year
tender documents have been prepared and
the construction phase is likely to be
programmed from April to June next year
this report seeks cabinet approval to
incur expenditure in relation to this
scheme in exactly sorry in excess of 250
000 pound which is making this a key
decision and up to the value of the
environment agency Grant I'll therefore
propose acceptance to you
thank you Council albums are second
Council Yates
uh councilor Rogers you wanted to speak
thank you leader
um the report says it's fully funded by
the grant so why is there a need to
incur further expenditure in the excess
of 250 000.
thank you
I don't think that's what it means
councilman Brothers I think what it
means is that any decision to spend
money over 250 000 wherever it comes
from has to come through cabinet and in
this case it's 880 000 or up to 880 000
which is coming through the environment
agency so there's no net outflow from
the council
thank you
I can't remember there's any discussion
on this one
okay so you've heard the recommendation
is agreed
great thank you
and we move on to number eight which is
the Viking Bay to dumps and GAP sea wall
repair scheme
right
um a 406 000 Grant has been awarded to
deliver this project
the scheme focuses on uh a one to 100
meter length of sea wall between
preacher's null at Viking Bay and to the
end of the sea wall just to the south of
dumpton Gap
the seawall here is 60 years old and
many of the structure components such as
the concrete apron blocks uh wave return
coping and concrete
beam slabs have become eroded by wave
energy tidal action and weathering
including freezing and Thor action
the council has 11 miles of Seawall and
such large-scale refurbishment projects
are an important element in the
maintenance program for our existing
Coastal infrastructure
without undertaking works of this nature
we will be in a position where the sea
wall and popular Coastal Promenade would
in time need to be closed for the public
on health and safety grounds
furthermore there would be a loss of
film material from within the sea wall
with a detrimental impact on our
internationally designated Coastline
this report sees cabinet's approval to
incur expenditure in relation to this
scheme it exists of 250 000 pound
making this a key decision and up to the
value of the environment agency Grant
or proposed you
thank you do you have a second
councilor Kate you'll need to get in
um councilor Rogers did you want to come
in on this yeah okay no same one okay
same question that's right
members any discussion
is that agreed great thank you
item nine is the tenant and leaseholder
services annual report councilor
Whitehead
thank you leader
tonight cabinet is being asked to agree
to an executive decision that involves
the approval to publish the tenant and
leaseholder services annual report
2022-23
I continually promote the work of our
housing team and this annual report
shows exactly why I do so
as a social housing provider the tenant
and leaseholder services need to produce
an annual report to achieve regulatory
complaints
this means that we have to provide
relevant information that enables and
supports tenants to scrutinize our
performance
this is the second annual report that
has been prepared by our team
and it's now ready for publication
and the clarity accessibility openness
and overall human approach clear
throughout this publication sums up not
only the professionalism but also the
hard work that our tenants and
leaseholder team put into daily support
and into supporting residents to
understand more about our services
to put them in the strongest possible
position to be actively involved
Advocate and work with us to deliver
change
the contribution of our frankly
wonderful tenants and leaseholder group
is also a parent throughout this report
and again this clearly demonstrates our
continuing work towards creating a
resident centered housing service with
community and service at its heart
I think it's very important to note that
this is a holistic piece of work
the actions completed this year the
priorities made the support provided to
continually improve our service comes
not only from offices but also from
residents from our tenant and
leaseholder group from counselor
feedback on issues and priorities
everyone involved in housing in
whichever way is valued and their
contribution clear
the direct work which our tenant and
leaseholder group did to not only
explain how we could improve our
communication and standard letters but
also to directly feed in and recommend
responses is invaluable
our routine communication is the
foundation of our relationship with
tenants and it needs to be accessible
friendly and open
as such tenant and leaseholder
contribution is essential
but the work directly put in by tenants
and leaseholders has to be recognized
and commended
the external training and policy
engagement exemplified by Tracy from our
tenant and leaseholder group with her
involvement in the tenant and Resident
engagement conference in London
demonstrates tenant and leaseholder
commitment to building a truly
reflective and inclusive service which
as she states has residents at the heart
of our housing policy
this is an essential corporate report
a legal requirement and a duty
but housing and our tenants and
leaseholders have made it far more than
that and it is a genuinely engaging
informative and accessible document that
not only clearly indicates what we do
exceptionally well but also shows
residents exactly where we want to be
and what we are working towards
housing isn't just buildings
it is homes
it has a heart
there is nothing clinical or cold in it
it is not bricks or mortar it is or
should be a study and practice of the
place we feel most safe of the community
We Trust of the people we love and of
the continual recognition of the
importance of all of the above
and this document isn't about housing
it's about homes and that is so so much
healthier than where we were before
writing the house service
we provide quarterly performance reports
to OSP and cabinet you will all be very
familiar with them and they provide
essential context on the services that
we provide and are also subject to the
same scrutiny by involved tenants and
leaseholders
but our annual report gives a chance to
take stock and look at not only our
team's performance
but also explore the reality of our
tenants experiences
and exploring both resident and team
stories with photos and case studies
allows for a full and engaging study of
what we do here
and also allows us to share times of joy
and achievement times of Challenge and
times that are just plain unusual
it's not every day that we get to take a
donkey to the 15th floor of Kennedy
house for filming and to be able to
document everything that goes into Life
as a tenant and as a housing provider is
priceless
inclusivity is vital
information means nothing if it isn't
presented in an accessible way and as
well as publishing our report on the
council's website we will also be
producing a plain text version that can
be read by a web reader and the web page
will include an equality statement that
invites people to request a printed
document or information in another
format
and hard copies will be taken to
community events to take away to ensure
that access remains at the core of our
decisions and actions
our tenants and leaseholders are at the
heart of all that we do
as such it is only right that this
report has already been reviewed by our
tenant and leaseholder group and it has
now also been scrutinized by OSP before
coming to cabinet for approval to
publish
this document is not about houses
although it discusses them it is not
about statistics although it includes
them
it is not about information although it
provides it comprehensively
this document is about homes
those who live in them those who help to
maintain them those who build
relationships to support residents and
those tenants who go the extra mile to
support other tenants with their
knowledge and commitment to always
making our service stronger
I am incredibly proud of Sally of the
tenant and leaseholder team and our
tenant and leaseholder group
without the concerted efforts that you
all make our service would not be able
to be the holistic and reflective
presence that it is
and what is produced here is genuinely a
community effort
thank you to everyone who makes this
service what it is and thank you to
everyone who has enabled us to share
what we do so effectively
I am privileged to work with and
alongside you and I will never stop
saying it
I move the recommendation to publish the
annual report on the council's website
thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead for your
typically comprehensive introduction
and to what I think is that I think it's
a it's a very informative and well
presented
report which contains a lot of good news
and is usefully accessible to
the tenants as well as the council which
is obviously as you've said important is
there a second of the recommendation
councilor Yates and
um councilor paper I'm not sure
councilor white has left you much to say
but I'm sure you'll find something thank
you thank you thank you councilor
Whitehead for the report yes it's just
an update on progress really I was very
pleased to hear that the recycling
scheme introduced at trovin Kennedy
house in ramgate has been well received
and is successful I know that many of
our tenants are Keen to participate in
schemes to make our planet greener has a
similar scheme plan for Royal Harbor
been implemented yet and when can we
expect to hear whether or not it had it
has or will be started at Brunswick
court please thank you
thank you very much councilor bayford
we're very keen that residents in our
blocks have exactly the same access to
recycling as any other resident would
have
um and you're right
um Kennedy and Trove it has been very
well received and the last Community
event that I attended confirmed that I'm
happy to pass over for the progress on
the individual projects
it's up to come for Albin if you'd like
to come in first
in relation to the recycling I mean
that's that's something that um when was
last in
power here I instigated to get
to trial it trovin Kennedy and it's
certainly something that um
I would and this and our service would
like to happen and to to go across all
tower blocks
across than it and uh yeah I welcome it
welcome it
hello yes hi
um yes it's we are really pleased the
way it's worked at Travon Kennedy and we
are looking to roll that out further
um to the other towel blocks but also we
have uh quite successfully rolled out
recycling to some of our
um medium rise blocks as well and we're
looking to do that across the HRA stock
seeking out areas where we can do that
educating and putting in recycling
thank you and of course that's that's
not just important to the residents in
those blocks it's also important to the
council's recycling figures because we
need to improve our recycling rates and
that's something that we will be
focusing on Mr humble weren't we
thank you okay members any other
comments
no so um
we're asked to authorize publishing the
tenant leaseholder service report to the
council's website which is an unusual
kind of decision
the members are great
thank you
item 10 is the annual treasury
management review
2022-23 which is Council Yates
thank you this report summarizes a
backward look on our treasury management
activities for 2022-23
the figures remain provisional because
our 21 22 and our 2022 and 23 accounts
have not yet been audited and are
therefore submitted to change until the
order is completed
firstly I'm pleased to report that all
our all our activities operated by
officers were within the limits agreed
by members although there was a Minor
error by one of our financial providers
which was picked up and reported in our
mid-year reports Council
the other key messages that I've
summarized are below the council's gross
debts also called the borrowing position
at 31st of March 2023 was 19 million
the council's underlying need to borrow
to finance's capital expenditure also
called the capital financing requirement
the CFR was 52.2 Million at 31st of
March 23. therefore it can be reported
the council has complied with the
requirement to hold less gross debt than
its CFR which is the capital financing
requirement the maximum debt held by the
council during 2022-23 was 20.2 Million
which is well within the statutory
authorized limit of 96 million our 31st
of March 23 the council's investment
balance was 60.6 Million
a marked reduction in general fund
Capital receipts over the last two years
is also highlighted in the port which
has implications for funding for the
future Capital program
um I moved the recommendations as
contained within this report
thank you Council ice is there a second
I go cancel the doctors this time
uh Council yes you might want to take
this opportunity there's a lot of
discussion in the media about
um councils issuing sexual 114 notices
and basically running out of money
um and I quite often see speculation
that from residents that that sort of
situation might occur at that do you
think there's any risk of that happening
at thanet based on the information
you've got we are in a very fortunate
position
um actually in compared with the county
councils and um
um for the first time in numerous years
we're not looking to make significant
budget cuts in the upcoming budget and
uh so I can categorically say yeah we're
not anywhere near section 114 notice
currently
I think Mr blunder will stay quiet on
that one for this evening I just think
it's worth I just think it's worth
saying that we do get all kinds of
sensationalist comments about the
council's financial position and whilst
local government Finance is very
difficult for everybody we are not in a
crisis internet and I think we need to
say that and make that clear
uh members it's been moved and seconded
uh the recommendations are does anybody
Wish You Something Else
is that agreed
thank you and we move on to item 11
which is the 2022-23 provisional outturn
thank you this support sets up
provisional year-end position for the
general fund housing revenue account and
capital program for the year ending 31st
March 23. as referred to previously the
figure's remain provisional because our
21 to 22 and 22 to 23 accounts have not
yet been audited and are therefore
subject to change until that order is
completed
the key financial messages are that our
general fund net revenue spending was
approximately 2 million pounds over
budget however this was in line with our
expectations as reported in previous
monitoring reports
the overspend can be fully funded from
the residual covert grant funding and
additional business rate monies as
indicated a 3.1 of this report
3.2 of this report identifies the
potential to make two separate
contributions to reserves firstly set up
and contribute 58 000 pounds to a new
digital Communications Reserve to
receive and allocate funds as
contributed as contribution towards
future projects
secondly to make a one-off contribution
four hundred thousand pounds to reserves
from the underspend on Capital interest
and principal payments which will be
available to be drawn down in 23 to 24
to fund the capital Investments for
toilets which I think everyone's got an
interest in that
due to an administrative hour though
this report which I missed was still
shows the recommendations presented to
our corporate management team so the
recommendations should read as follows
the cabinet notes the following the
provisional outturn position for the
general fund the provisional out term
position for the general fund Capital
the provisional out term position for
the housing revenue account and the
provisional out term position for the
housing revenue account capital
and number two the cabinet agrees the
following that cabinet agrees the
provisional to the proposed Reserve
movements has identified as section 3.1
and 3.2 to this report that cabinet
agrees the slippage in the general fund
Capital program is identified in section
six of this report and the cabinet
agrees a slippage in the HRA budgets as
identified in Section 8 to this report
so I move those revised recommendations
thank you
um any discussion members
no are those recommendations agreed
thank you
and we move on to item 12 which is
Council Yates again budget monitoring
2023 24 report number one
thank you
um this is the first budget munching
report for this current year uh we are
forecasting an overspend of just over
489 000 pounds against our general fund
Revenue budget there remains pressure on
homelessness and in response to this the
council has reviews reviewed and is
delivering its homelessness strategy
action plan
we're regularly monitoring the level of
homelessness and have been recruiting
more staff and commissioning new
services to address the increased need
for the support
other Financial pressures of detail in
the report in the report they include
additional agency Staffing requirements
in the waste and recycling service
potential increased costs associated
with seaweed removal as well as income
shortfalls
moving to our general fund Capital
program it is showing a substantial
underspend this is in part due to the
phasing and timing of a number of Grant
funded projects some of which will be
reprofiled and slipped into later years
of this program
I'm also pleased to report that the HRA
is forecast to come in under budget by
199 000 pounds
finally there are a number of budget
adjustments that are detailed within the
report that are recommended for cabinets
approval
I move the recommendations contained
within the report
thank you Council Yates is there a
second
councilor Keane
and councilor Davis you wanted to speak
on this awesome I think
thank you leader
um
I think it's uh
to be commended what I want to say and
the question that I have relates to nx1
in the general fund Capital program
um firstly it's excellent news to hear
and have confirmation that the previous
conservative Administration left you
with good funding and and a good stable
opportunity Rob so congratulations
um what I would like to ask is related
to several items in the general fund
Capital project
one of which we're coming back to
Ramsgate Paul birth Forum five
replacement could I just confirm because
there's a lot of confusion over what's
been spent on this and the budget has
251 249
allocated only 117 spent is that the
case that this that that money has not
been spent and that's still in the
budget and the and the birth is complete
um that's that's my first question
following on from that uh an urgent
decision was given in February to spend
60 000 pounds which we were told at ons
I believe it was
um was for electrical work to do with
this birth
um the question remains whether it had
electrical facilities previously however
in the capital program report there's
reference to sixty thousand pounds the
same figure for a Transformer are we
paying an additional sixty thousand
pounds on top of a quarter of a million
pounds to support a commercial
Enterprise that isn't even using the
berth
that's the other part of my question and
final little one is uh there's 105
allocated for the sluice Gates what's
happening with those because they're
allowed they're not working obviously
and haven't been used since 1980 so I
wonder if you could clarify thank you
thank you cards to those I'm not sure
all of that really fits under the budget
monitoring report number one but we'll
exercise some discretion
um
I'm not sure that casually ice is
equipped to talk about sluice Gates we
might we might pass that over to Mr
Humber but Council Yates
yeah thank you so
um the report makes clear that on burst
four and five to start with
um there has already been spend of 117
um thousand pounds
um versus the 251 000
um budgeted for 20 23 24.
um and
I forgotten what what was your question
in this was it just that um it's what's
actually been spent uh Rob if you could
because
um there's 251 000 there according to
these figures uh to June only 107 or
only but 117 have been spent
um if so why because this project has
had its funds funding increased on
several occasions so why was that done
if it's been delivered for half what's
on the on the sheet
um and why didn't it include the 60 000
for the Transformer when that's in the
spec that was on the original
specification
why has that come up as an Earth this
light because this council is still
paying Brett's compensation for a birth
that has been sitting there for a year
why are they not using it we're still
paying and we're paying 60 000 to
support them on top of everything yeah
um yeah that's understood um I'm I don't
know the exact detail but I will pass
over to Mr Humber
um to to specify the exact timing on
some of those payments and uh also the
Transformer question thanks thanks Rob
sorry it's a complex but
okay uh yeah thanks for your question
counselor Davis so the birth or five
project this is um spend to date the
final account for the project is yet to
be completed there will be more spend
and I think it's something that we need
to update on when that has been when
that final count has been completed and
then we'll you know there'll be a figure
that can be reported so I think that's
the that's the reason for that in the
you mentioned about uh a Transformer
well go back to the birth the electrical
Works uh have been completed the birth
was
a new birth put on stage it's had a
previous life but it's a new birth put
on station at Ramsgate without any
electrical installation so that was the
electrical Works to
um put Power and lighting and the you
know the navigation lighting and the
things that you need on birth
um the Ramsgate Port Transformer is a
separate project it's not
um specifically related to the Brett's
project it's about
um ramsca the porter landscape it's got
three substations and Transformer
facilities to um uh you know bring the
voltage down and just distribute it
around the around the site and the last
question was I think about the sluice
Gates which is not the same as the
um the flap gate miter Gates or lift
bridge site this sluice gate is there
used to be seven sets of sluices which
with pen stock valves which allowed you
to empty the inner Marina this is about
the ceiling of the last set of those
that haven't currently haven't been
sealed
um so that's a it's a separate project
um if I could just ask why they're being
sealed because they're part of the
smeaton's design of the harbor which is
supposed to keep the gullies clear if
they're being sealed we're doomed to
having to dredge in an inappropriate
location those gullies are part of the
integral operation of the harbor
councilor Davis I think well let Mr
sorry sponsor that if you want sorry
later that's a yeah this is a financial
report not not my apologies for the
report and I think
um there will be other opportunities to
discuss support and harbor and I'm sure
you'll be joining me in those
discussions absolutely and thank you for
your Indulgence and sorry if I've got a
bit off track there
I'm happy to
talk to councilor Davis about the the
reasons for that scheme but it's about
improving the resilience
um they are already sealed but in a in a
nature that needs to be made more
permanent so they are already sealed
um like the other six sets of of
solutions but perhaps happy to happy to
talk about that
okay thanks Mike
right thank you
members any discussion over an above
birth four and five or in relation to
this report okay
um it's been moved and seconded the
members agreed with the recommendations
thank you
we will move on to item 13 which is the
department for leveling up houses and
communities funding updated
simplification Pathfinder pilot
[Applause]
[Music]
um I think we can indulge your counselor
Bainbridge thank you
so this is for me to
um
introduce
this report comes to Cabinet um at the
end of a process which has seen the
council Lobby central government for
simplification and we've been making
requests because we have three separate
Capital programs which funds have been
awarded as members know they are the
future High streets found the town deal
and the leveling up fund projects
which together
um total over 50 million pounds for
projects across Ramsgate and Margate
um we take as an indication that we have
been one of the more successful local
authorities in the country that we have
been
um selected uh as one of ten local
authorities in England and one of two in
the Southeast to take past in this um
simplification Pathfinder project it's
important to note that it is about
governance and managing reporting back
to central government it's not about
starting again in terms of deciding
where the funding should be spent
the projects themselves have already
been agreed they've been through the
formal government approvals
that are included in this pilot program
so the key elements of this Pathfinder
is that there will be one single
allocation of money across the portfolio
of projects
however the funding will be managed
within the council's processes on a
project by project basis
so the allocations to each project are
as they are as they were
um is simply that the council has more
flexibility in the way that it reports
and um
manages them
there will be a single set of outcomes
and outputs covering the full portfolio
of activity and these are outlined in
ax1 and these are profiled across five
new intervention themes enhancing
connectivity unlocking and enabling
commercial development strengthening the
visitor and service economy improving
the quality of life of residents and
employment and education
the output and outcome indicators are
very similar to those that were already
in the town deal and leveling up fund
programs which may consolidating the
targets across the whole program easy
the reporting will be streamlined so
there will now be one three monthly rag
report red Amber green focusing on spend
and progress and one sixth monthly
delivery report which we hope will
significantly reduce the administrative
burden
improvements to the change management
will mean that we will not be queuing
with other local authorities in an 8 to
12 week approval process for any project
adjustments
approval from dlac will only be required
if we wish to make what they call a
material change which is considered to
be over 5 million pounds between the
projects
and we'll have one main contact in the
dlac area team for discussions about the
pilot
central government requires the council
as the accountable body for this funding
to establish a Consolidated governance
structure which will be a strategic
oversight board and we're required to
have certain people on the board
including all levels of government
County districts and town councils the
MPS for the area
businesses and or investors and
communities Representatives
to be clear this isn't a decision-making
board
it will support the council in reviewing
delivery budgets time scales risks and
the monitoring and evaluation process
as the accountable body any decisions
made in relation to this program will
follow existing Council processes and
procedures including overview and
scrutiny with cabinet being the ultimate
decision maker
having improved contact with dluck will
help us with our broader engagement with
them we also welcome the fact that
through our engagement with the
Department they've concluded that we can
and should be part of this pilot our
understanding is that the outputs will
be used to inform dlac on how they
engage with local authorities in the
future on these Capital programs in
order to understand how they better
deploy and manage the funding
and one thing that I wanted to say in
particular is
it was clear to me that as soon as this
came forward that they could be
concerned that Ramsgate funds would go
to Margate and Margate funds will go to
Ramsgate we are not going to do that
were we to propose to do that it will be
a decision that will go through the
council's processes and everybody would
have the opportunity to comment on that
but that's certainly not the intention
and I think the two towns people in the
Two Towns would need to understand that
so um the recommendations
are to note the details of the submitted
investment plan on the basis of the
profile and spend the delivery against
the intervention themes approve the
disbanding of the Margate Town Deal
Board in order to set up new and
relevant government arrangements for the
simplification Pathfinder pilot approved
the recommendation set up a new
partnership board with final recruitment
of board members to be in consultation
with the leader and approve the
Project's been included and delivered
through the new Amalgamated
simplification Pathfinder pilot as
identified in section 4.1 which is all a
bit of a mouthful considering that what
we're trying to do is make things
simpler
so those are the recommendations do I
have a seconder
counselor album
um
so I have a number of members I think
well perhaps I don't I just have Council
of Bainbridge
thank you leader
um so my question is that
um who who will be sitting on the
partnership board and considering the
need for all councilors to understand
any changes that may be made within each
award whether that be the leveling up
fund or the Margate Town deal
would you consider ensuring that their
representation on the board from all
political parties
I think I can confirm that there will be
representation on the board from all
political parties
over and above the MPS
so um yeah I don't think there's any
intention to um
reduce the political participation on
the on the existing panels let's put it
like that so both labor and conservative
councilors
members elected members who are not MPS
will be represented on on the new board
and we haven't finalized the makeup of
it completely but um I'm sure I think
Miss Askew wants to come in
thanks so within the report it
identifies the representatives that need
to be included so all levels of
government
um and then we will have two business
representatives and two Community
representatives and the intention is
that they will
um be larger organizations that
understand about spending big sums of
money how you manage it how you manage
risk being able to
um Challenge and ensure that we're
sticking to time scales Etc so those
organizations will be approached and
we're just working through a kind of
short list of those at the moment but
the the ambition is that they either of
um broadly than it based or they we have
one for each town and then that will be
approved through the leader
just ask another question just quick one
based on what Louise said
um how how are you coming to the short
list for your organizations and to
participate in this
so as I know you're aware we don't have
an awful lot of large
um businesses and or Community groups in
the district so it'll be a relatively
short list to start with
um and from the experience of the team
we'll be working through those
identifying the ones that we think have
um the best opportunity to offer in
terms of the board and then we'll have
discussion with those
um its own as it is only for members
that the thought of doing a call out was
you know it would take too much time and
um we need to make sure that we move
into this next phase quite quickly as we
are starting to move forward in terms of
delivery of the projects
right and as I've allowed councilor
Bainbridge to ask a question I'm going
to ask allow councilor bright to as well
thank you leader
um I raised this in the overview and
scrutiny panel on
when was it Tuesday
um and I'm going to write it again
um
I think
I I personally would like some
to to have agreed a a certain regularity
of reporting of these projects I don't
think it's going to be enough for
elected members who sit on either
overview in scrutiny or governance and
audit I'm the vice chair of governance
and audit as well
um to receive reports on progress every
sort of two or three months so if we can
get more regular updates that would be
really good
I think in terms of formal updates
through the council's committee process
I
was asking and I've talked about this
and I think we see a need to be
reporting back to members but we also
have to be realistic about the role of
overview and scrutiny which cannot be to
review the delivery of every project
individually
so we are going to come up with a
reporting format which we hope will
satisfy overview and scrutiny but as we
said earlier on
um
the point is that the decisions will be
made through the council processes and
the council processes have opportunities
for Challenge and interrogation and
ultimately the decisions are made in
public at meetings like this so
um
I think we we talk a lot I mean we must
we mustn't confuse overview and scrutiny
with the role of portfolio holders who
are there to challenge officers and make
sure the delivery is happening and in
some respects the role of other members
is to challenge the portfolio members to
make sure they're doing their job
but this is a very major program it's a
very significant issue for the council
it's a very big opportunity for the
council
um it's just a couple of things I wanted
to add
you know I've seen people talk about
slippage in delivery
well clearly
there's a bit of slippage in delivery
which has taken place since May but
there are some fundamental things about
the way these projects these uh funds
were structured which has led us down to
where we are currently
um
I happen to be talking to members from
two other Kent authorities who've got
leveling up fund Awards this morning and
both of them were saying although
they're not part of the Pathfinder
projects as far as I'm aware that
they're looking they won't be able to
deliver before 2026.
um and I think that it's a common issue
that
District councils
have not been fully equipped to manage
the level of capital funding which
they've been awarded and this partly
flows from the fact that the funding
system is haphazard and unpredictable
which means that we can't retain the
staff that we would need
to deliver these schemes completely and
that just that isn't just about project
management it's about the procurement
process it's about legal issues so what
we've had to do as a council and
obviously the previous administration
was involved in this is
um Gear Up in order to be able to
deliver these projects so whilst we
welcome the fact that we've got more
flexibility in in the um in the new
arrangements and we welcome the fact
that there's actually an extra year
allowed that doesn't mean to say that
we'll be delivering everything in March
2026 and there will be delivery before
that and there is work going on at PACE
and people will see evidence but I think
to be honest with you the original time
scale set by the government were
unrealistic
um and that's what we're seeing not just
in thanet but across the piece
um and I don't think if people would
look in detail at what's happening in
other authorities that they'd find that
there's
a mark difference in their in what
they've been able to deliver to what
we've been able to deliver but this
isn't it's an exciting time
um for all of us and I'm certainly
looking forward to the outputs and I
know that everybody is and I'm convinced
that we're going to have some
really exciting developments over the
next few years
okay
um
members
okay so there's no discussion so let's
agree remember
thank you
and we move on to item 14 which is
coastal zone maintenance contract
yeah thank you
um
Senate has as I said previously static
has 16 miles of Coastline with 11 miles
of sea walls our Coastal infrastructure
also includes upper Promenade railing
steps Bridges groin slipways and Cliff
facing walls all of these assets are
maintained via the term maintenance
contract
the existing five-year maintenance
contracts is due to expiring January
2024 a new contract proposed with the
three-year term and a two-year extension
option
this is base budget Revenue funded work
and is informed by a regular detailed
inspections of the coastline undertaken
by our Technical Services team
without this contract we would be unable
to react to Urgent work or routine
repair work to ensure that we get the
maximum work in life out of our Coastal
infrastructure
we would also be open to an increased
Insurance liability as a result of
unresolved deflects on the defects on
the coastline the budgetary value for
this work each year is 244 000 pounds
but there are occasions when there is an
advantage to delivering other
maintenance work via this contract and
the contract value is therefore set at
three hundred thousand pound per annum
or 1.5 million over five years
this report seeks a cabinet approval to
incur expenditure emulation so this
maintenance contracts in excess of 250
000 pounds over the full duration of the
contract term making this a key this
decision I recommend the
recommendation the recommended
recommendation
thank you
Roger did you want to speak on this one
so
later
as grants were awarded for broadstairs
flat and Coast protection scheme and
Viking Bay to dumpton Gap sea wall
repairs scheme why is there no grant for
the coastal zone maintenance contract
did we apply for a grant
Mr hammer
um thank you councilor Rogers for your
question the reason is that this is a
maintenance contract so maintenance is
revenue funded so
um the environment agencies flood and
Coast or erosion fund is about Capital
Improvement so the two schemes at
broadstairs are capital schemes they
they um you know they are large schemes
that deliver improvements
um our maintenance program can only be
funded via Revenue uh money and it is uh
you know historically that is always
funded by a
um you know our tdc's own budgets
okay
any discussion members
um is that agreed okay
item 15 is the LED Street lighting
conversion project
which is cancel out
thank you I didn't even know here we go
um the LED Street lighting conversion
project is included in the
2023-24 capital program with a budget
allocation of 283
000 pounds
a contribution from broadstairs and some
pieces Town Council of up to an
additional fifty thousand pound has also
been secured to undertake works of
Victoria Parade and on the broadstairs
Harbor including the provision of
festoon Lights
the council is responsible for
approximately 500 street lights around
the district this project will will
result in improvements to approximately
200 of those with Works included either
a new LED lamp or an entire LED fishing
a new column or a combination of these
elements
the project is well aligned with the
council's Net Zero strategy the
conversion to LED technology will not
only reduce electricity consumption it
will also reduce the number of required
maintenance visits to replace failed
lamps
a specification for the project has been
prepared and the works are anticipated
to start in January 2024 with completion
planned by July 2024.
this report seeks cabinet approval to
incoa I can't say that word incur
expenditure in relation to the capital
projects in excess of 250 000 pounds and
up to the allocated Capital program
budget making is a key decision
thank you councilor Alvin do you have a
second
councilor that was
and I'm afraid Castle but I can't resist
making the observation that's entirely
appropriate that you should speak on an
item about lighting
okay
very good
um
yeah so no question uh here just a
comment really
um over the summer
broadstairs and St Peter's Town Council
began work on
um our first ever cohesive forward plan
of projects not quite sure what they've
been doing for the past 50 or so years
but there you go
um this plan is going to set out the
council's agenda for the next four years
um the plan itself was based on three
strategic pillars and the leader kindly
came to the town Forum
um it's it's designed to foster a
cleaner safer and Kinder broadstairs on
the 28th of July the Town Council held a
forum attended by members of the public
and representatives of over 30 Community
groups including the leader we use this
forum as an opportunity to learn about
the issues that really matter to the
community and the 40 Lighting on the
seafront particularly around Victoria
Gardens and parade was regularly
mentioned as something that makes people
feel unsafe in their surroundings to the
extent that many people avoid this area
after dark this project is a is
therefore of great importance to the
residents of broadstairs and St Peters
and to the town and the Town Council was
delighted to approve a contribution to
the project to ensure delivery before
next summer
and restoring light to the seafront the
project makes broadstairs safer
delivering on our promises to the people
of broadstairs and Peters
although apparently Net Zero isn't worth
worrying about anymore
by using environmentally friendly low
energy LED fixtures this project helps
broadstairs and St Peters become Kinder
again delivering on our promises to the
people of broadstairs and Peters
so as a new Council I'm proud to be part
of this labor Administration that
continues to deliver these important
projects and to have a positive impact
on the lives of our residents so thank
you very much everyone is involved in
this
thank you councilor bright and um
certainly I was impressed by the
enthusiasm and the ideas of the groups
that you had represented at your meeting
in broadstairs which I attended and I
look forward to seeing further outcomes
from the discussions because it all
seemed quite constructive and sensible
to me
um
casserole just come back on that on on
what council brighter said
um I'm just pleased to to see that you
recognized our leader as a community
group thank you for that
um okay members any discussion councilor
Kane
not discussion really just to recognize
that I think you know with our aims to
reduce emissions and our importance of
safety for the area this is a really
good initiative that I'm pleased to see
we're working on and both issues are
very important to our residents so I
think they will appreciate it too thank
you
thank you councilor king
um
members has been moved and seconded are
we agreed thank you
and finally item 16. the planet District
Council electricity Supply tender
Council Yates thank you Linda this
report seeks authority of the council to
enter into a new contract for the supply
of electricity to 264 sites within our
portfolio
the cost of the new contracts can be met
within the approved budget the council
is required to ensure best value for
money when we're growing its contracts
and as such the council is required to
re-procure its electricity Supply
contract before the renewal date of
first of October 2023 the value of the
estimated contracts is detailed in the
report and exceeds 750 000 pounds and is
therefore a key decision you should be
noted that the electricity supplier will
be provided on a renewable tariff for
the time of the contract signing
therefore aligns with the council's Net
Zero strategy I move the recommendations
contained within the report
thank you Council Yates you have a
second though
councilor wirehead
any comments members
is that agreed
thank you very much that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting I declare
the meeting closed at 8 10 and the live
stream of the meeting will now end thank
you